how he deals with his toughest
competitor yet and we see the handshake
there as Magnus Carlson as usual shows
up three seconds before the start of the
round
yeah it's some kind of a mind game you
let your opportunity to a very lost
moment the handshake and the game is
about to begin we will keep our eye our
close eye on the Carlson kymer match and
on hikaru's attempt to wheel his way out
of a difficult situation do not go
anywhere folks we will be back with more
World Cup action on the other side of
this short right which was a very mature
decision it was a hard decision because
he left Magnus with this outside passer
on B5 and Vincent realized that even
though his own Pawn majority was less
Advanced that it would ultimately decide
the game and it just has a historical
moment Vincent kymer defeats Magnus
Carlson the highest rated player in the
world in chess history in the first game
of their mini-match what a huge moment
Peter
and Vincent making sure he stays
hydrated there
it's the first time you've beaten Magnus
carts in the classical vein surely yeah
I mean we've played a lot of games also
online and I don't even know if I've
ever beat them in a bullet game I had
winning positions against him quite a
few but I think I've never managed to
beat him and of course we are doing it
here in such an important game it's
great tonight holy smokes
it takes on C3 yes he takes on C3 and
look at Magnus he looks aside it's
clearly indicates that he has noticed
Knight takes E4 but it was so tempting
for Vincent he thinks like glow is
enough I think the Queens what can
happen to me it's a very solid position
but Manus cannot believe he is look at
this he's just completely shocked of
what happened
oh my gosh a huge Miss by Vincent but
let's not overstate the case he's got
fantastic chances of holding that end
game but my goodness Knight takes C4
would have likely sent him into the next
round so easy to miss against anybody
but particularly from a nut nothing
position out of the Clear Blue Sky a
tactic like this is exceedingly hard to
see so definitely understandable Vincent
playing the move quickly and I wonder if
magnus's reaction maybe tipped him off
to the fact that something existed and
Rook B7 threatening Rook V8 check and
Bishop G2 Rook returns captures G7 with
a fork on The Rook of the bishop Vincent
might resign here
it's up to the greats and to the chess
professionals to push that pain away
it's a 1-1 score they're gonna play a
tiebreaker tomorrow and there's the
handshake Magnus Carlson wins on demand
he defeats Vincent kymer after his loss
yesterday with a beautiful end game
display and takes this match to what is
going to be an incredible tiebreaker
tomorrow oh what's what's the problem
and then I immediately saw 94 and I
thought now that's the World Cup so I
just went to the bathroom
you know more like in
disbelief
then than anything else uh and uh yeah
when I came back he played Bishop C3
uh
you you know I took back and uh I
expected that to be that but
yeah then he took on C3 and honestly I
was I was so shocked that I could barely
you know
yeah I
yeah then it's then it's a game it's
just a fairly straightforward win after
after that so that was
um yeah some serious breaks for me today
for um for sure whose game is that it's
pregnant
oh officially knocking out yeah
what enough said there we have on this
day break very well done by these Indian
Prodigy and Magnus Crimson approaching
him congratulating and probably yeah
congratulating him I think he's telling
him some lines most likely I would think
so no he should be congratulating him
too wow notice you stood up actually
during your game and you congratulated
Bragg when he knocked out Nakamura what
did you say to him
um we uh we have a um my chess club
official there they have a camp right
now for young talented players and um
in Stockholm Sweden and where Ramesh
prague's coach is like he's the main
coach and um
one of my friends who attended the camp
he was saying yesterday that
um
Ramesh is always telling us be like
Prague be like
uh so I just told Prague that uh yeah we
all want to be like you today
[Music]
oh
thank you
[Music]